je m'appelle odile je m'appelle julia il
y a dix on comptait sur les doigts de la
main les pionniers de la conférence
gesticulée chaque année plus nombreux
ils sont aujourd'hui près de 600 à se
produire dans les bars les mjc les
théâtres pour faire de l'éducation
populaire c'est-à-dire instruire faire
réfléchir et rire aussi
mais qui sont ils et pourquoi ont-ils
besoin de gesticuler comme ça je
m'appelle françois je suis chanteur
musicien comédien
même quand j'étais môme je voulais pas
du tout faire ça moi mon truc c'était la
bande dessinée humoristique mes héros
c'était gaston lagaffe les tuniques
bleues obélix achille talon
la musique n'était pas c'était pas mon
univers familial culturel
il est parti pour nous raconter sa vie
françois parce qu'une conférence
gesticulée cessa dérouler le fil de sa
vie pour le mérite
au fil d'un savoir théorique lui veut
alerter sur l'urgence écologique plus
forcément des milliards d'années devant
moi et j'ai envie de faire vraiment ce
que je quand on commence à la flèche
comme ça à se remettre un peu en
question
on a fait depuis plusieurs années tout
simplement affection peu plus loin puis
on se dit mais est ce que tout ça c'est
pas lié à des injonctions sociétale à
des systèmes de domination à des
déterminismes sociaux etc
on commence à faire le sociologue
amateurs et puis et puis on en arrive à
faire une conf rejoindre la grande
confrérie des conférenciers gesticuler
ça ne se fait pas seul dans son coin il
faut suivre une formation pour associer
au fil biographiques et théorique
un troisième fils celui de la mise en
scène
l'enjeu du stage consiste à tresser ses
trois fils comme pour fabriquer des
petits scooby doo
les participants viennent d'horizons
divers intermittents du spectacle joueur
de tennis ou chefs d'entreprise ils se
retrouvent régulièrement pour faire le
point sur l'avancée de leurs travaux
l'idée c'est que ce soir on va décider
le capitalisme y en a qui vous
promettent le grand soir moi je vous dis
le grand soir ça va être là maintenant
on ne sortira pas de cette salle enfin
voilà enfin cette c'est une proposition
vous n'êtes pas obligé et là je vais
aller boire un coup
grand soir jeu
pas du tout je préférais que je préfère
que tu partes sur l'idée d'un tu pars
sur ce que tu veux m'aimer mais je
trouve que partir sur un petit soirée
monte en crescendo ça prend plus de sens
je vais rejoindre ce qui a été dit par
un julia par enfin plusieurs d'entre
vous oui son côté un peu un peu donneur
de leçons mais le fait de dire
enfin je vais abattre le capitalisme
fait tu toi vous savez tous faut que la
façon autrement tu vois surtout surtout
mais je reviendrai que tu ne démontre en
rien c'est ce que je trouve finalement
le plus intéressant c'est pas tellement
de la jouer cette conférence mais c'est
ce qui se passe ici on est six
stagiaires qui arrivent ont chacun avec
une thématique différente et on
travaille à 6 et cette émulation autour
de sujets qui sont tous est éminemment
politique bien sûr elle est extrêmement
extrêmement agréable en fait ça fait du
bien de sentir que on n'est pas les on
n'est pas tout seul dans son coin a
essayé de se poser des questions et elle
c'est de trouver quelques réponses
mais voilà ça booste en fait ça fait un
bien fou
je suis musicienne enfin je suis je sais
pas si je suis musicienne ou gelée était
en tout cas j'ai pas réussi dans le
milieu de la musique pour gagner ma vie
pour payer mes factures et est un peu
bouffé exige des petits jobs est bas du
registre la conférence gesticulée n'est
pas une thérapie donc tout elle donne la
parole à ceux qui habituellement ne
l'ont pas comme thierry ancien géomètre
qui n'avait jamais mis les pieds sur une
scène avant de devenir lui-même
conférencier et puis formateur
on essaye dans l'est dans les stages
d'écriture de conférences gesticulées
d'insister sur cette question du langage
parce qu'elle est tout sauf anodine nous
sommes fait manipulé depuis 40 ans par
le langage quand vous appelez un plan de
licenciement un plan sauvegarde de
l'emploi et que vous acceptez ce terme
là vous êtes noir vous pouvez descendre
dans la rue pour gueuler contre un
licenciement
vous allez avoir du mal à gueuler contre
la sauvegarde de l'emploi
cette prise de parole illégitime
c'est ça la subversion du site
c'est à dire que le système les
puissants les dominants détermine qui
est légitime à prendre la parole et tous
les autres ne le sont pas et donc se
définir comme légitime à prendre la
parole c'est subversif c'est là je veux
dire quand une aide soignante
quand une aide à domicile quand viennent
prendre la parole raconter ce qu'elles
vivent mais ça n'est pas uniquement un
récit de vie c'est-à-dire elles partent
de ce récit ville pour en faire une
analyse politique
quelques 5 % des femmes qui sont
instrumentistes ok donc là moi je viens
d'intégrer parce que je suis comme je
reste encore sidéré encore aujourd'hui
ça veut dire que moi je me suis projeté
dans un travail où je me dis tiens je
vais faire de la musique je vais être
dans le monde de la musique maintenant
en fait j'ai peut être de la musique
je vais être dans le monde des hommes
qui font de la musique
le vent nous femmes esclaves et briller
en eau entrave debout debout debout
debout tabou de vous ça a démarré dans
un cercle ou schiste
mon corps
donc c'est très très restreint au début
je veux dire quand il ya quinze convives
qui existe ouais en journée on joue dans
des bars de van de ven 15 personnes mais
petit à petit ce cercle s'agrandit
le fait qu'ils en aient 600 aujourd'hui
fadili iam et puis youtube fin et les
réseaux sociaux internet etc fait que ça
commence à se savoir
c'est le paradoxe assumée par ses
adversaires du système grâce à google et
youtube la conférence gesticulée sort de
l'entretoit et surtout grâce à franck
lepage qui cumulent des centaines de
milliers de vues et qui remplit les
salles là messieurs
celle ci est un parapente
je me suis mis au parapente parce que
j'avais raté mon ascension sociale
c'est ex animateur socioculturel a créé
le genre en 2004 quand il s'est retrouvé
au chômage
un programmateur du festival d'avignon
avaient décelé son talent comique et lui
a proposé de monter sur scène
depuis il fait le tour de france en
passant par la touraine pour diriger des
formations avec un groupe d'une
trentaine quand le festival d'avignon
pour me mettre dans leur catalogue du
off 2000 1400 spectacle me demande dans
quelle rubrique on doit me m on dit vous
mais en théâtre alors j'ai dit non non
non c'est pas du théâtre clown je vous
en prie compteur j'ai arrêté je me faire
lyncher par les compteurs donc ils
disent oui d'accord mais on met quoi et
ça me vient comme ça parce que je sais
pas quoi dire
j'écoutais m'étais conférence
gesticuler en fait ça veut dire quoi
c'est bien une conférence c'est à dire
qu'on va bien apprendre des choses sur
les politiques publiques sur le
management devrait sur le sujet on va
vraiment apprendre quelque chose mais
pas depuis une position d'expert en fait
gesticuler ça veut dire c'est
intraduisible et tout le monde comprend
donc depuis hier ce qu'on fait émerger
c'est la question c'est 2-2 première
étape c'est la question du fils de
savoir chose que l'on appelle le savoir
show qui est donc notre savoir
d'expérience ce qu'on a vécu ce qu'on
sait ce qu'on a découvert les
participants de cette formation sont là
pour construire une conférence
collective ils sont psychologues
agriculteur en retraite chômeurs
rassemblés par la communauté de communes
de loches
à la fin ils seront tous ensemble sur
scène pour parler de la santé publique
et privée et quelques années elle mon
père a déclaré parkinson dont santé et
la neurologue lui dit va écouter on à
50% j'ai 50 ans en ne passant pas qui
est plus de 50% des patients
parkinsoniens qui sont anciens
agriculteurs
deux ans après je suis passé en
agriculture biologique dans le monde
militant une phrase que vous entendez
souvent c'est raconte pas ta vie ta vie
ça nous intéresse matin vie ça vaut rien
ce qui nous intéresse c'est aline
politique c'est ton analyse politique et
ça ça donne un tract hockey or un tract
quand on ose un tract on attend que la
personne est tourné le dos on le froid
et en le balance donc là là je dirais
l'apport peut-être restons très modeste
1 mais l'apport de
de la forme conférence gesticulée au
monde militant c'est précisément
l'incarnation de la personne dans son
autobiographie c'est à dire je vais je
vais militer je vais vous parler de la
domination capitaliste
je vais vous parler du mensonge des
compétences du du je vais vous parler du
massacre des travailleurs avec les
logiques d'évaluation de l'état mais je
vous en parlais à partir de ma vie parmi
les paroles de parents je prends la
parole est là bien un truc énorme kim
qui me submerge une colère et là je je
dis à tout le monde
j'en peux plus moi ma fille elle
m'empêche de dormir
elle me bouffe ma vie je peux plus
m'occuper de moi j'en ai ras le bol je
voudrais qu'elle meure et là le
psychologue me dit c'est normal que tu
sois en colère après ta fille mais en
fait tu ne sais pas envers ta fille que
tu en colère c'est envers son handicap
je suis là parce que je suis la mère
d'une jeune femme handicapée de 34 ans
et que en fait je viens parler du
handicap je viens parler de notre
parcours c'est une occasion vraiment
rare enfin je crois que c'est l'occasion
de ma vie de défendre tout c'est tout ce
que j'ai à dire sur le handicap tout ce
que tout ce qui va à l'encontre des
idées reçues sur le handicap j'ai envie
de défendre ces personnes là les gens
qui voient une conférence gesticulée ne
se disent pas j'ai pas fait théâtre je
suis incapable de monter sur une scène
mon dieu mon dieu ils se disent pas ça
ils se disent ça je peux le faire ça il
faut que je le fasse c'est vital au
départ c'est ce qu'il ya dans tout
conférence gesticulée c'est à dire une
personne arrive à un moment de sa vie où
soit elle fait un cancer soit elle fait
une conférence gesticulée c'est à dire
soit elle arrive
cette personne a transformé toutes les
contradictions qui font qu'elles
arrivent en burn-out qu'elle arrive à ne
plus trouver de sens dans ce qu'elle
fait professionnellement elle en fait
quelque chose c'était elle en fait un
objet politique publique partageable
elle le met sur une scène
[Musique]
la conférence gesticulée c'est comme le
tango
les premiers pas peuvent être hésitant
mais avec un bon partenaire tout le
monde peut y arriver à chaque
représentation quelqu'un dans le public
se dit pourquoi pas moi
et à la fin ils espèrent la conférence
gesticulée ce rare internationale et
sera le genre humain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]